we all know that jon snow knows nothing
but the actor behind the bastard of
winterfell definitely knows what makes a
game of thrones series tick house of the
dragon has enormous dragon sized shoes
to fill even considering the
controversial final season of game of
thrones disappointed viewers were
clearly still curious about returning to
westeros and tuned in to the
record-setting premiere of the dragon
filled prelude in droves there are power
men should never have trifled with
hbo aims to keep up the heat for the
game of thrones franchise with a variety
of spin-offs currently in development if
they all move forward fans can expect to
learn even more about house of the
dragon's coreless velarion in the sea
snake following his adventures forming
one of the greatest naval forces in
westeros four ships have now been lost
the last one was flying my banner we'll
also embark on an epic quest with
princess nymeria the fierce warrior arya
named her direwolf after i'm here
most surprising of all however is a
sequel to the original series centering
on the lone half targaryen wolf jon snow
given that kit harrington now has skin
in the spin-off game fans have been
eager to learn what he really thinks of
house of the dragon an early perspective
on house of the dragon that stood out
from the rest of the game of thrones
cast came from harrington who told the
associated press in august 2021 it might
be painful to watch you know there's so
much tied up in that that i might find
it hard you're right
this isn't your fight
you shouldn't have to come to winterfell
with me i shouldn't be asking you
it's not the deal we made two months
later the classically trained actor told
insider i think to see people get into
outfits and costumes that resemble what
we wore for all those years but not be
in it is always going to feel there's
going to be a rawness there i wish them
all the best but it's so close to my
heart that story that of course there
might be a bit of pain there but now
that house of the dragon is officially
here and four episodes deep harrington
has some thoughts on the popular series
at the world premiere of his new film
baby ruby he told entertainment tonight
canada that he's watching and he likes
what he sees i'm really enjoying it i
think they've done a fantastic job
harrington then brought up the
complications in undertaking such a
monumental spin-off saying it's a weird
one to start a whole new show in the
same kind of realm and to make it its
own thing and i think they've really
done that what do you want me to do with
this
wear it
bernie
whatever you want
additionally he noted his good friend
miguel sapochnick is the showrunner on
the series giving him an extra incentive
to watch according to the hollywood
reporter sapochnick is exiting house of
the dragon as showrunner however but
will stay on to executive produce
harrington and sapochnick spent a good
bit of time together on the game of
thrones set where the latter directed
six episodes including battle of the
bastards e.t canada then tried asking
about harrington's expanding role in the
marvel cinematic universe following
2021's eternals but having years of
secrecy training under his belt from his
time on game of thrones he remained
tight-lipped about any unofficial black
knight news
you